now that we've all been stranger thanks
three let's talk about the season's
ending toasts amigos turn on the boombox
and watch out for the mine flare from
shocking deaths to shifts in the status
quo to what we can expect from season
four this is the ending of stranger
things 3 explained spoilers ahead after
a lengthy battle stranger thanks 3 ends
with an emotional departure as the
buyers family sells their little house
and Hawkins for a new life somewhere
else will has to say goodbye to his
friends
Jonathan has to say goodbye to Nancy and
L has to say goodbye to Mike and the
life she's been building with hopper we
don't know exactly where the family will
settle but it's a tearful upheaval that
changes the landscape of the show
forever this whole story began with four
friends Mike will Dustin and Lucas as
they were swept up in an otherworldly
adventure after a night of playing
Dungeons & Dragons now at the end of
stranger things 3 the state of the party
has changed in a major way will the gang
reunite in season 4 what could bring
choice Jonathan will and 11 back to
Hawkins perhaps another crisis taking
place over a holiday celebration and
then I was thinking maybe you could come
up here for Christmas and we'll - it can
come before or after Christmas or
whatever misses by response but the
three months later epilogue for the last
episode of stranger thanks three begins
with a clip from a news report that
suggests that dark and mysterious goings
on of Hawkins are becoming publicly
known in some way in the past the
government's been able to keep a
relatively tight lid on things but not
anymore
now with the town's mayor in handcuffs
and reports of everything from chemical
leaks to the tragedy at Star Court
making the rounds Hawkins is gaining a
reputation on a national level
shortly before stranger things threes
final battle at Star courts 11 port
every drop of telekinetic energy she had
into ripping the last shred of the mind
flayer out of her in the wake of that
effort she was unable to even crush an
empty soda can with her mind at the time
she seemed to think she just needed to
recharge as she always has but then the
seasons epilogue revealed that she still
didn't have her powers back after three
months does this mean her powers are
gone forever it's possible but unlikely
the series got far too much mileage out
of Elle's superpowers so while we may
end up waiting in a long while for 11 to
find her mojo
for powerless arame let her take some
time to learn a little more about being
a regular teenager the seasons
post-credits sequence reveals that the
Soviets have managed to capture a
demagogue on and they're keeping it
alive in a cell by feeding it a steady
diet of prisoners what exactly they plan
to do with it is anyone's guess but it
can't be good this is all made even
creepier by the fact that we still don't
know exactly what the Russians hope to
do with the knowledge gained by opening
the gate or how they managed to figure
out so much about how to get into it in
the first place are there more Russian
spies working on this exact problem
embedded in Hawkins right now is their
tech strong enough to open a new gate
now that they've had time to work on it
again that corrosive green liquid be
used to power anything else can the deme
Gorgon become a trained killer there are
so many questions here and none of them
have having answers Chief Jim hopper
lived through a lot on stranger things
but he couldn't really survive the
explosion of the key at the end of the
season he knew it was necessary for
Joyce to blow it up as quickly as
possible it was a noble sacrifice and a
fitting end for a great character or was
it the post-credits scene makes it clear
that the Soviets have someone in their
cells they refer to as the American
Jenny
yeah Megan
could that unseen American be hopper
consider this the show goes to great
pains to show us how destructive the key
explosion is it shows us several Russian
scientists who are flat-out vaporized by
its power but it never shows the same
thing happened to hopper this show has
shown us the corpses of everyone from
Bob - barb - Billy over the course of
three seasons to make sure we knew those
characters were dead but we never see
hoppers body is that because there isn't
one if it's really true he's gonna have
a honey of a story to tell when he gets
back to the states then again there's
another potential candidate for the
Soviets American prisoner dr. Brenner
Elevens Pappa who we were told in season
two isn't as dead and buried as we
previously thought
Brenner I can take you to him is gone no
he is a lie stranger Thanks three
doesn't end in a self-contained way it's
many dangling plot threads from the
future of the Byers family to what
exactly might be going on in Russia all
suggests the sense of a continuing story
and that is indeed the plan according to
an Entertainment Weekly interview with
stranger things executive producer Shawn
Levy the current plan for the series is
for creators Matt and Ross defer to tell
a story that lasts at least four seasons
if not five so we should definitely
expect more from the Hawkins gang the
real question now isn't if but when
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]